jordan says it has foiled a plot by a
former crown prince to destabilize the
kingdom
the government maintains hamza bin
hussein and others were undermining
security
with the help of foreign powers now as
many as 20 high-level officials
have been arrested hamza denies being
part of a conspiracy
and says he is being silenced
according to jordan's security officials
the king's half-brother
hamza bin hussein had been under
investigation for some time
the country's foreign minister said the
former crown prince was trying to
mobilize tribal leaders
against the government with support from
abroad
the investigations monitored
interference including calls with
foreign parties regarding the suitable
timing to start steps to shake the
security of our steady jordan
16 people including a former adviser to
king abdullah
and another member of the royal family
were arrested
the military initially denied arresting
hamzabin hussein
and said it had issued him a warning for
his actions
but in a video statement sent to media
on saturday
prince hamza claimed he had been placed
under house arrest for associating with
critics
of the royal family there is no
conspiracy
i am not part of or aware of any
conspiracy
all that has happened is that my
movement has been
restricted that my ability to
communicate has been restricted
but people have been arrested to try and
distract
from the fundamental flaws that have
become so common in our system
as a result of poor and incompetent
governance
though he no longer holds an official
title hamza remains a popular figure in
the country
in my view it's just not right for
prince hamza to be linked to these
people
these are people who jordanians see as
questionable
who are really frowned upon
we do not want to see anything no matter
how small
happened in this country this country is
known as stable and secure and i ask
god to have this country remain stable
and secure
and many sees stability in king abdullah
ii
he has enjoyed widespread popularity
during his reign
jordan is widely seen as an island of
calm in a troubled region
strategically located between israel
syria
saudi arabia and iraq the us
uk and several arab nations have all
expressed their full support
for the reigning monarch
and for more on this i'm joined by dw
reporter
ibrahim and she is following that story
for us the
authorities have essentially accused
prim prince hamza of of plotting a coup
it's it's very serious this charge
good morning to you christine well it's
also extremely unusual
for a feud of this kind to be happening
in a country
like jordan it's almost unheard of to
see senior members of the royal family
uh you know be at odds the way that we
have in
the past two days but you are right that
the accusations are
extremely serious we saw uh the you know
prime minister
deputy prime minister um ayman asafoeti
yesterday
say that they have you know tracked
calls and interface
between the former crown prince and
powers discussing the timing of you know
action to destabilize
the country allegedly according to the
deputy prime minister
they've also said that they've tracked
calls uh between
again a foreign agent a foreign power
something very vague
and the crown the former crown prince's
wife uh
telling her that uh you know a plane can
be available at the time of her choosing
to take her out of the country i mean
these are essentially
accusations that are to mount to treason
accusing a former crown prince
of such serious accusations to
destabilize the country
absolutely serious and very
unprecedented
prince hamza is said to have had foreign
support in in this alleged
plot have authorities said anything
about where that foreign support might
be coming from
they haven't they've stayed uh very
vague about who
what this foreign support could look
like what possible countries could
be behind it so i mean all we can do is
is guess
and and speculate but i i will say that
this excuse of uh her people in the
country
trying to destabilize it with the help
of foreign power is a line that we hear
unfortunately all over the arab world
often times
to silence dissent oftentimes to rally
popular support behind
the ruler uh of of of the country
against any kind of descent
or anybody who falls uh out of lines we
don't know if that is
you know we have no concrete information
as to whether that is indeed the case
in jordan but it definitely is something
that we've heard
uh to um to to to sideline
critique around the region right and we
also know that there's been a
long-standing feud between prince hamza
and king abdullah but could
could these developments be be a signal
of wider discontent
in in jordanian society
i think it's very reflective of the
moment in
in jordan perhaps i mean jordan is a
country with very few resources
uh and um you know the kovit 19 pandemic
has hit this country
quite hard especially with some very
harsh lockdown some of the harshest in
the region actually
and so you know there is economic
discontent
uh of course um the country is also you
know um
host to something like 1.3 million
syrian uh refugees
so it is reflective perhaps of the
economic situation
uh but um we have to
we have to wait and see if it's
reflective of a bigger feud between
uh the king and the former crown prince
all right that's
a ibrahim from the dw news team thank
you aya
and for more on this we're joined now by
amar al-sabela in
a man he's a political analyst and
columnist
um the deputy prime minister is accusing
prince hamza of working with what he
calls foreign parties to
undermine the security of jordan what
does he mean by that
uh well actually this is surprising this
is a very surprising statement by the
foreign minister
and actually um we usually in jordan
we don't have any um let's say
um enemies or somebody or or any foreign
power that is interested in
destabilizing the country
so basically this was a bit surprising
and as long as the foreign minister
talked about this i guess there should
be
also concrete evidences for that so
basically this might
lead to a new um let's say
confrontation for jordan with this new
reality although
we in jordan believe and that there's
nobody
targeting uh the internal situation of
jordan
so the issue is being explained as well
from the reaction of most of the
countries
uh to the issue uh yesterday happened
yesterday like the support the
endorsement of king abdullah came from
all over the world
so this means that in reality we don't
feel that there's anybody
interested in this destabilization of
jordan so
i think uh the government is obliged
soon uh to reveal these concrete
evidences
in order to be credible and especially
also for the internal audience and the
jordanian public opinion yeah i mean
when he talks about foreign parties
there's a could be a number of countries
including saudi arabia your neighbor
who where mohammed bin salman has been
engaged in a number of foreign
adventures
are people talking about that as a
possibility
well uh i don't think that there's an
evidence for that simply
um maybe the announcement of that
resting of
allah who works with the mohammed bin
salman
might lead to this but let's not forget
that king abdullah's
last visit was to muhammad bin salman
and he went alone with the crown prince
and this might be linked also um to
what's happening here
then immediately the first country to
endorse
his majesty's efforts what was the saudi
arabia
this means that um
politically speaking or diplomatically
speaking uh there's no real proof that
the saudis might be interested in such
issue otherwise
i think their award allah wouldn't have
been arrested in this way
well could the problem be not a
potential
enemy but a definite and confirmed
friend i'm thinking of the united states
here which recently announced
an agreement which would allow the free
entry of american troops onto the
kingdom's territory could that be a fact
or somehow some resentment about that
well this is interesting but to be
honest this kind of military
cooperation and agreement has been uh
all over the years
so there's nothing new in that that
might lead for a new
event let's say or be a trigger for a
new movement
i doubt that this is is linked
to any of these issues i think it's more
domestic issues
um the issue of crown prince the
you know the presence of recently like
in or in the last three years
prince hamza has been a bit active on
social media tweeting
criticizing the situation recently he
was very active visiting people
tribes etc and this might
in a country which has one head and one
crown prince
that might lead for a kind of opening
a kind of competition or bringing to the
people's mind a kind of alternative and
this is i guess this is the whole issue
the issue of the stability of the of the
regime itself
the crown and the crown prince
especially and the king so basically i
think it's mostly
related to domestic issues and the way
uh prince hamza was
behaving in recent days well just to
talk about those domestic issues briefly
and the relationship between
the two royals prince hamza spoke of
poor and incompetent governance
in that video without naming the king
but could this be the remark of a
of a bitter half-brother deprived of his
status as crown prince or
is there truth behind what he's saying
well uh it's not new that he left
uh his status as a crown prince it's
more than 15 years now that he's not a
crown prince
so basically i don't see a direct link
between that especially that he after
that he wrote a very famous letter
saying that he has no desire or appetite
for governance
and he would understand this then he
appeared in recent years mostly
engaging in domestic issues so it's not
it's something
unusual surprising to see that these
words which is common in jordan by the
way recently in public opinion there's
very high criticism for the public the
poor
let's say governance of government but
being said from a member of the royal
family is a bit shocking or surprising
and for sure it's risky because it opens
um let's say a kind of
fraction which is uh not the story in
jordan
the strength of jordan is based on the
strength and unity of this family
right uh we never would that so if i
want to remember
uh in in the previous uh era of king
crossing it was very smooth
transition and therefore it's a bit
surprising
okay well thank you so much for helping
us try to understand this surprise
political analyst amir al-sabih in a man